très incidents de niveau 1 sur une
échelle de 7
voilà ce qu'ont déclaré les centrales
pour l'année 2014
sur cette même année l'asn l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire a effectué 136 contrôle
des contrôles qui permettent d'évaluer
le niveau de sécurité des installations
première de la classe la centrale de
saint laurent
elle se place même au dessus de la
moyenne nationale viennent ensuite
dampierre-en-burly et belleville qui
sont dans la moyenne
la centrale de belleville obtient même
un bon point en matière de protection de
l'environnement
chinon a été longtemps la dernière de la
classe par manque de rigueur dans le
respect des procédures en surveillance
renforcée depuis 2010 elle a connu 90
inspection en quatre ans à la demande de
l'asn
elle devra s'améliorer sur trois points
en particulier le premier c'est ce qui
concerne la rigueur d'exploitation
pendant les essais périodiquement les
essais qui sont faits régulièrement sur
les installations pour s'assurer de leur
bon fonctionnement
un deuxième point d'attention se la
surveillance des prestataires d'edf fait
appel à des prestataires pour des
opérations de maintenance ou
d'exploitation sur ces sur ses
installations
il faut qu edf applique une surveillance
appropriée sur ses installations
et puis enfin dernier axe d'amélioration
c'est sur la prise en compte du retour
d'expérience
donc le fait de tirer tous les
enseignements des événements des années
passées durant cette année 2015 l'asn va
porter également toute son attention sur
la centrale de saint laurent
le réacteur numéro 1 passe actuellement
sa troisième visite décennale
l'occasion de faire un check up complet
des installations et de vérifier leur
conformité à l'issue de cette visite
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
autorisera ou non l'exploitation du
réacteur